with black lives matter and all of those
who seek social justice and equality
sports can be a powerful agent of change
and it's our hope that we can build on
this moment to be a part of the positive
change needed in our country
tonight's starting pitcher it'll be
shane bieber he will be our nissan
starting pitcher and bieber coming off a
very fine year at 15 and 8 and 33 starts
at 328 earned run average he uh is a 3-0
in his career against kansas city
salvador perez he was out all of last
year he hurt his arm in spring training
and had tommy john's surgery and missed
the 29th team campaign
breaking ball is ripped up the middle
and into center field and
salvador perez
today
is playing in his first big league game
in over 600 days and then coronavirus
and his timing has not been affected at
all the royals
pitching tonight is led by danny duffy
this is opening day start number three
for danny that's right danny duffy has a
chance today to set the tone especially
for his team jose ramirez had the brutal
start
and then jose ramirez for two months in
july and august was arguably the best
hitter in the game
left field deep gordon back looking up
it is off the top of the wall
ramirez
steamrolling his way into second base
with a one-out double
i think he got that a little off the end
of the bat being a change-up and that
didn't have to carry
the pitch
mcbroom takes strength three on the
outside corner fastball painted it
mcbroom is bieber's second strikeout one
down now the o2 pitch
a swing and a foul tip hung on to by
roberto perez
and bieber has struck out three in a row
franco
out number two here in the scoreless
second
the pitch
and strike three called he painted the
outside corner what an inning for shane
bieber
as shane bieber strikes out the side he
is struck out four in a row
the one-two
fastball in there he was guessing with
two strikes boy i don't know how you
guess against shane bieber with two
strikes
bieber has now struck out five
and when you're fourth in the cy young
vote you're one of the elite pitchers in
the game the [ __ ]
swing and a miss breaking ball got him
well here's a guy he walked in the first
time
he hit him
off the play that might have been
but bieber has been around the plate
that's why you don't want
bieber to get ahead of it because he can
throw pitches like that and make you
chase
[Applause]
he went around the ball goes to the
backstop perez from his backside able to
throw him out about that terrific throw
by perez who he fielded the carom well
but then his feet went right out from
under him
but he never panicked
michael franco takes a call third strike
and now he's beefing with home plate
umpire dan isonia
but that is ten strikeouts for bieber
here comes the o2 from bieber
called strike three went off speed
dropped it on the inside corner and
starling could not pull the trigger
strikeout number 11.
miss he stayed with it did you see that
fist pump you know that felt good that's
a dozen k's for shane bieber
good hitters count three and one you
want to be very selective with a a pitch
here he hasn't seen a fastball yet there
it was bangs it up the middle and it
gets by monday the indian strike first
as luplow scores roberto perez goes all
the way to third and oscar mercado
drives home the first run of the year
for cleveland it's a one-nothing ball
game in the fifth excellent at bat
fernandez shoots it by the third baseman
[Applause]
[Applause]
he just stayed on that ball didn't try
to pull it
and look at him that ball tracked deep
about into the plate
and just slaps it by franco with third
race for a double
up the ladder he goes with a fastball in
perez couldn't help himself a dirty
dozen 13 strikeouts now
the wind and the pitch
swing and a miss what a way to end it
with a changeup he strikes out alex
gordon another new club record 14
strikeouts for shane bieber the most
ever by a cleveland indians pitcher on
opening day
that'll be his night
[Applause]
hold on by roberto perez and good night
mikhail franco
that is out number two
one-two pitch swung out and miss hayes
struck him out brad hand
has his first game and the indians have
their first win
as they shut out the kansas city royals
by a score of two to nothing